На малій батьківщині Тараса Шевченка, у селі Моринці,
киплять не лише польові роботи.
Коло Шевченкової хати, де вже на повну силу квітне
вишневий садок і ось-ось загудять хрущі,
готуються до туристичного сезону.
Тут вперше прозвучав голос малого Тараса.
У такій колисці його мати колихала, як він писав - "свою нудьгу переливала"
55-річний науковий співробітник заповідника
"Батьківщина Тараса Шевченка"  Станіслав Суржко
то Шевченкові вірші читає, то хрестоматійні історії з біографії розповідає.
З 92-го року проводить екскурсії - виключно українською.
НовинІ про те, що Верховна Рада ухвалила закон
про забезпечення функціонування української мови як державної, зрадів.
Хоча поки не знає, які саме обов’язки це покладає на нього як держаного службовця.
Які поправки в законі, я не знаю  поки що.
Коли буде надрукований, тоді прочитаю і скажу.
Треба пропагувати мову, щоб вона звучала довкола.
А ті, хто говорять російською мовою,
вони почують милозвучність цієї мови, її ніжність.
Законопроект передбачає, щоукраїнською вільно мають розмовляти
не лише керівники країни, але й держслужбовці органів місцевої влади,
судді, адвокати, викладачі та медпрацівники.
Олег з козацьким прізвищем Мамай викладає в школі"захист вітчизни".
А в 90-х був міліціонером.
Згадує, що ще тоді в правоохоронних органах
вимагали перевести документообіг на українську.
Ми розуміли, що так потрібно. Дуже тяжко було.
Ви уявляєте, що ми раніше 12-ої ночі додому ніхто не йшов.
Для нас це була катастрофа,
коли ми з російської мови перейшли на українську.
Разом з тим він переконаний: чиновники мусять володіти державною мовою.
Якщо людина не розуміє державної мови,
то який з неї керівник?
Державної!
Якщо тобі не подобається українська мова,
то я так думаю, що тобі і держава ця не подобається.
Так думають у Моринцях не всі.
У відомого місцевого майстра по дереву Віктора Зорькіна
свого часу замовляли вироби іВіктор Ющенко, і Віктор Янукович.
Щоправда, останній так і не заплатив.
Тепер  чекає на замовлення від новообраного президента Володимира Зеленського.
Він не поділяє думки, що українській мові потрібен окремий захист,
і не проти, якщоновий глава держави спілкуватиметься російською.
Якщо йому легко на російській, хай говорить на російській,
від цього шкоди не буде нікому.
Хай сам обирає, якою йому розмовляти.
Згідно з новим законом, на телебаченні, радіо, в інтернеті
та друкованих ЗМІ, у театральних виставах та при дубляжі кінофільмів
також має використовуватися українська мова.
Те, що за останні п’ять років, за рахунок квот на телебаченні
та радіо, україномовного продукту стало значно більше,
подобається 69-річній пенсіонерці Вірі,
яка займається зеленим туризмом.
Звичайно, раніше і Ротару, і Пугачова -всі співали.
І російські пісні теж непогані, я нічого не скажу.
Але зараз мені вже українські подобаються.
Тепер у її, так би мовити, плей-листі інша музика.
Пам'ятаю оці ось - Kozak System, "Колір ночі", "Тартак"…
Деякі зірки навіть зупинялися у господині.
Їхні прізвища, як і імена інших туристів, записує у спеціальний зошит.
Цього року, щоправда, приїжджих поки було небагато.
Пояснює це фінансовою скрутою і виборами -
людям поки не до відпочинку.
Втім, сподівається,що за нового президента все буде інакше.
Він нам обіцяв, що курс Порошенка не змінить.
Не те, що Порошенка, а України на українськість.
Ми сподіваємося. Будемо думати, що все буде добре.
За Володимира Зеленського у Моринцях проголосували три чверті селян.
Від нього, як і скрізь в Україні, очікують переламних змін.
Тим часом команда Зеленського вже заявила,
що збирається переглянути закон про мову.
Адже остаточний його текст, з урахуванням усіх поправок, поки недоступний.
Команда Зе хоче пересвідчитися, що в ньому дотримані
всі конституційні права й інтереси всіх громадян України.